andré dussollier
et
on va isoler honnêtement qu'est ce qu'il
vous perdre dans des endroits pareils
vous que tu ris c'est une grande
première
bah oui on la sait je suis flatté bas
nous aussi on est prêts place est plutôt
rare en télévision non plutôt oui ça y
est je passe pas mal de temps à
travailler
et le plaisir de jouer les rôles me
satisfait pas vous avez dit d'ailleurs
le besoin galopant de notoriété
pervertit tout nous sommes désormais
invitée dans les émissions de télévision
non pas pour parler de notre métier mais
de notre vie ça attaque
j'ai eu et on va parler un peu des deux
vous avez 55 en 30 ans de carrière vous
avez fait plus de 50 films avec le lou
chabrol rennais sauter scola vous avez
fait trois hommes et un couffin qui est
un monument national
la suite va bientôt sortir 18 ans après
avec le même casting vous effet on
connaît la chanson
chef-d'oeuvre les enfants du marais qui
a séduit beaucoup de français 40
téléfilm 20 pièces de théâtre est ce
qu'on peut dire bravo du pavot est dû
non j'ai encore plein de choses que j'ai
envie de faire mais je sais pas
l'appétit vient en mangeant donc il ya
des rôles il ya des que je n'ai pas
abordés des gens aussi que je n'ai pas
assez exploré
donc non ça s'arrête pas j'ai pas envie
que ça s'arrête
vous avez une actualité ou c'est comment
on fait avec les petites mains comme
quand on est déçu quand vous êtes prêt
attention attention dussollier faire ça
c'est mon bonnet attention bien voilà
alors vous avez une actu des charges et
un d'abord faut dire à ceux qui ne
savent pas que vous êtes la voix off du
carton de l'année 7 million et demi de
spectateurs amélie poulain le narrateur
c'est andré dussollier vais pas été
payés au pourcentage c'est le problème
quoi
un personne si tout le monde avait su
bien sûr ils m'ont auraient été payées
ou récente a eu un cachet mais oui mais
c'était très content elle ferme la terre
cette fois c'était tout à fait inattendu
et puis c'est un personnage qui qui
compte alors aprilia vidocq fait le rôle
du préfet de police est un personnage
très dessinée très caricaturer corse et
redingote chauffe très étonnant
personnage très très étonnant ça qui
casse un peu votre image diaries rang
amusé c'est à dire de faire des
personnages très différents c'est un peu
le privilège de l'âge je sais pas ou de
l'addition ldd film donc vous dont vous
avez par le parisien je vais prévenu
oui
[Musique]
j'avais marée noire perçage qui gère nom
et ma vie quand on commençait mal à les
voir à la barre hier ces jeunes est tout
à fait alors vous êtes né en 1946 oui
vous avez passé l'enfance à cruseilles
dans un village à côté de thonon les
bains dans une maison bleue adossée à la
colline une chanson ça si on connaît la
chanson j'ai fait comme elle m'a dit ah
oui mais certaines ententes c'est une
maison qui était adossée à la colline en
plus c'est vrai mais l'habitant voilà
vous êtes suisse unique et vos parents
travaillent et aux impôts aussi un
courant qui s'es un bel hommage
on connaît la chanson on connaît la
chanson c'est le cas de le dire on
arrive à la question là on arrive à la
fiche 69 ch et que la fille 66 ans non
c'est pas porno du tout mais les rôles
sont inversés
versez vous que j'ai déposé mon cas j'ai
envie vous en faites par andré quand
même alors posez moi n'importe quelle
question qui vous passe par la tête chez
obligé d'y répondre
pourquoi est-ce qu'on vous copie temps
thierry et courtois
et pourquoi et pourquoi
pourquoi ça vous énerve autant ça
devrait vous flatter vous fait d'être
copiés c'est plutôt flatteur
voilà ça prouve qu'il ya pas beaucoup
d'idées dans le paf en ce moment n était
pas assez embarrassant s'est pas
embarrassé bien alors donc cruseilles
mille habitants c'est pas c'est pas
énorme 1 4 enfants par classe rapidement
quand on est quatre par classe ça vous
oblige à être bon moi que ça on à
l'instituteur cascades pas mauvais non
plus deuxième d'un jeu troisième étude
extrême solitude rien à verser 1000
habitants en cas de par classe les
parents aux impôts bon rêver c'est vrai
quoi là d un jour et un jour vous avez
enfermer un camarade il est enfermé un
de ses camarades dans une dans sa
chambre ouais il voulait partir ils en
avaient assez et marre de jouer pendant
depuis trois heures avec moi et là j'ai
paniqué j'ai affirmé en effet je voulais
pas qu'il s'en aille
j'ai réalisé quand même que j'étais en
train de commettre un acte un peu
étrange et donc j'ai rouvert la porte
mais c'était pour vous dire ma détresse
on est donc dans cette solitude ya un
grand bouleversement heureusement à
l'âge de 10 ans votre prof de français
vous emmène voir poil de carotte de
jules renard et là vous découvrez qui a
finalement des gens qui sont payés pour
faire rire voilà et ça c'est génial
tout ce que je ne pouvais pas faire
vraiment dans la vie c'est à dire
pleurer rire enfin je sais pas il y
avait pas tellement d'interlocuteurs en
es 4,1 donc là tout d'un côté avec en
plus des personnes qui étaient là dans
une salle qui applaudissait qui paient
même pour voir ça sert j'ai trouvé que
c'était formidable de pouvoir libérer
des émotions que dans la vie j'avais
tendance
et puis donc ça c'est paul théâtre répit
au cinéma le premier film que vous voyez
ci les 400 coups de truffaut
ça a été autorisé par l'office
catholique donc ils avaient le droit d'y
aller et c'est rhénan basse que quelques
années plus tard vous ferez votre
premier film avec avec truffaut c'est
extraordinaire non oui évidemment vous
voyez les 400 coups mais vos parents
vous dise passe d'abord tombe à 15 qui
disent je dise à tout le monde vous
allez être très serré comme garçon très
obéissants très enrichissant gentil
garçon super obéissant il va à la fac de
grenoble si vous dites à la fac de
grenoble quand même joué piétiner les
pantalons sans respecter les plis parce
que la maison fallait bien faire le plus
de fantasmes ou à les gérer tout comme
il faut en apparence table j'avais un
petit peu des excès mais que je ne
racontais papilles quand je suis passé à
grenoble
là il y avait un peu de kilomètres entre
la main amie et moi et là j'ai pu vous
ressortez l'université avec une maîtrise
de lettres modernes et une licence
pendant une maîtrise de lettres modernes
et une licence de linguistique mais j'ai
tout oublié suis absolument incapable de
vous interroger sur la philologie vous
refuser un poste à oran oui d'assistante
fidèles d'agir justement pour monter à
paris la voie là vous devenez élèves de
2 périmony de cocher vous allez au
conservatoire et c'est là que truffaut
vous voyez vous vous choisi vous jouiez
léonce et léna exacte et sur scène en ce
moment d'ailleurs à paris et vous fait
faire un premier film une belle fille
comme moi hein vous vous déguiser parce
que c'est vrai que là on parlait de
vidocq tout à l'heure c'est vrai que
face à bernadette lafont donc banquiers
comme moi vous avez des lunettes des
gants jaunes sérieux
rogner un peu pour pacino de oui c'était
l'époque c'était l'époque où il y avait
aux fans pacino de niro et caetera et
pour moi c'était ça le métier de
comédien on les reconnaissait pas d'un
rôle à l'autre et là avec ce rôle là
c'était un timide introverti du net et
tout bon donc je j'ai joué j'ai composé
un personnage mais finalement je les
payais un peu après parce que on
s'attendait à ce que j'ai des gants
jaunes des lunettes
quand vous êtes vus vous êtes dit quand
même pauvre apprentis du cinéma qui va
jouer comme dustin hoffman et ya peu je
suis pas encore assez armé à mon avis
pour le fait même mieux mais c'était
quand même une approche truffaut avait
l'air content et de films étaient pas
totalement truffaldien si on n'a pas
super bien marché
non il n'ya pas super bien marché alors
échec du premier fait d'une certaine
façon oui toute une vie avec claude
lelouch un échec aussi oui difficile ocb
d'artifice et le bruit c'est bien j'ai
commencé par le plus dur
donc après ça a démarré en fait avec
trois hommes et un couffin on peut dire
que j'ai additionner des films comme ça
mais publiquement c'est vrai que c'est
le film qui a eu le plus de succès vous
êtes très discret sur votre vie privée
d'aujourd'hui 1
je suis aujourd'hui normes il est très
discret ce soir
non mais bon il ya un truc tout le monde
le sait on peut en parler ya
prescription en bref tout ce qui veut
dire andré je ne vois pas venir du tout
pas du tout venir c'était sans doute une
relation
sexuelle très longtemps disons pas calé
sexuelle ça peut être gênant si vous
étiez très proche d'isabelle adjani à un
moment on était collègue ancien collègue
c'est vrai on est comment ses collègues
de l'art dramatique on était en est
commencé ensemble à la comédie française
mais je connais beaucoup de collègues
des collègues vendée c'est que dans
l'état font a déclaré donc sur le
tournage d'une belle fille comme moi on
pouvait pas trop lui parler en dehors
des scènes parce que dès qu'il avait un
moment de liberté
il s'éclipse et pour écrire à johnny
aimé célébrer quelque chose à lui dire
cg et j'aurai encore beaucoup de choses
à lui dire je m'aime beaucoup elle est
un peu happé par sa notoriété non adjani
après très tôt mercredi
c'est vrai à 18 ans elle a connu un
immense succès avec la gifle donc je
pense que c d changement de vie radical
qui sont pas forcément faciles à vivre à
cet âge là voilà vous l'avez aurait vu
je les croise et oui y compris je n'ai
non ya pas de sous-entendus je vais
croiser et après après dans la loge et
elle a félicité
nous avons beaucoup parlé
il se lit comme vous êtes un mec honnête
très très honnête
un look interprovincial pas showbiz du
tout je vais vous faire une interview
mensonges dans les ruches maintien
pendant les jeans galles c'est bien mais
pas bougé c'est parfait vous voulez
toujours en limousine avec les vitres
fumées
oui j'adore ça tous les matins quand
j'accompagne les enfants à l'école
j'aime bien rêvé par les codes et c'est
vrai que les idées allaient beaucoup
c'est vrai c'est une on aime bien voir
les acteurs de cinéma reid en limousine
et vous avez des assistants qui vous
allumez vos cigarettes sur les plateaux
coup j'en ai beaucoup je change souvent
est-ce que non mais c'est vrai c'est
difficile de supporter de la vie
quotidienne d'un acteur donc un bien il
faut pas s'emmerder exercice géant tous
les jours assistant un des assistants
préfère oui oui oui je sais on vous a
beaucoup vu à saint tropez cet été avec
arthur avec carlos avec collaro et avec
nagui s'est passé l'été avec eux oui
vous avez déclaré en parlant de ses
vacances là enfin je revis et vouloir
trouver quoi c'est à dire que ils ont
ils ont des bateaux énorme et ça ça m'a
permis grâce à eux d'éviter loana
il ya longtemps que j'avais arrêté
l'héroïne la cocaïne plusieurs années
non allez vous êtes au courant
ouais quelquefois j'aimerais away
aujourd'hui fumer quand même pétards par
jour ça dépend pour l'émission la whey
pas beaucoup pas beaucoup beaucoup et on
voulait bien parce que il a du mal et
pourquoi tu me regardes
donc on rencontre souvent avec de jeunes
actrices dans l'est dans les soirées
mondaines à des collègues des amis dans
les premiers rangs
votre épouse accepta très facilement
j'ai l'impression non elle est pour
et parce que
mais le sais que je reviendrai toute
façon et valorise à d'accord finalement
ça se passe bien c'est un couple moderne
je suis perdue mois là il ya un truc que
je comprends pas c'est cette passion des
clubs échangistes regret je ne peux pas
aller dans un club échangiste on vous
voir comme l'a dit titoff la dernière
fois ouais c'est pour rencontrer des
animateurs télé face pour aborder la vie
dans la chambre des officiers
j'accueille andré dussollier
comment on va les y oblige à regarder
arriver avec des yeux j'aimerais
tellement regarde comme ça mais vraiment
alors mais il m'a aidé à me relâcher ou
femme
huawei oui oui un bon temps encore ce
livre comme ça c'est fait ça c'est réglé
eric vous voilà à ben oui c'est recevoir
l'ordre alors deux spectacles théâtre
andrea les athlètes dans leur tête
monstres sacrés sacré monstre
et puis deux films un long dimanche de
fiançailles 36 quai des orfèvres à la
réunion avec une promo pareil vénitien
passage dans ocean's twelve on le voit
dans le bar de dos alors on va commencer
par le théâtre 1 vous reprenez au
théâtre de la gaîté montparnasse en
alternance une semaine sur deux par un
jour sur deux monstres sacrés sacré
monstre et athlètes dans leur tête
alors monstres sacrés sacré mons et des
textes de victor hugo de d'alphonse
allais d'alfred de vigny et puis les
sacrément c'est plutôt farceur du
billard quel connard voilà c'est une
sorte d'anthologie comme ça personnel
qui est que je me suis amusé à composer
mais comme une petite pièce de théâtre
qui sera écrite par plusieurs auteurs
vous avez un texte avait envie de faire
ça en vrai la matin le deux monstres
sacrés sacrément j'essaie de me souvenir
et demeureront chez garée sur un petit
texte comme ça qui est en plein milieu
du montage
assez court 1 assez court bien que le
morse d'ordinaire soit un animal
débonnaire il ne faut pas trop l'excité
on sait que les morses vont vite quand
quelque chose les irrite rien ne peut
plus les arrêter seul et je ne sais trop
grâce à ken amorce les moujiks en russie
on biton le pouvoir de les faire rentrer
soudain dans le devoir
moralité le moujik adoucit les morts un
groupe s'appelait le chat noir et l'or
c'est un des poètes de ce groupe là
alors y'a monstres sacrés sacrément
seuil athlètes dans leur tête donc mise
en scène et interprétation de vous
envoie du soulier sur des textes de paul
fournel alors c'est une espèce de
dommages aux grands sportifs parce que
vous dites les grands sportifs
finalement plus on les filme - on les
connaît c'est explorer s'approcher plus
près qu'une caméra ou un micro
oui c'est vrai paul fournel qui connaît
bien le sport et qui venait bien les
sportifs les fait parler comme on les
entend jamais parler et dire des petites
choses comme ça en général les sportifs
c'est vrai il ya toujours un devoir de
réserve ne veulent pas déplaire aux
sponsors à l'entraîneur donc pendant
qu'ils exercent leur passion il parle
pas beaucoup et là paul fournel l'effet
dire des choses intimes de leur
difficulté pour sept petites secondes de
gloire il ya beaucoup de souffrance de
doute et c'est très savoureux même si on
connaît pas bien le sport mais c'est et
en plus je me suis amusé à les
représenter en pleine action parce que
toute façon ils sont décrits en pleine
action il ya le footballeur qui rate une
reprise de volée ou cdc des petits
moments de vie de sportive qui sont ya
par exemple il ya par exemple le match
om psg il ya le joueur qui se met à
gamberger omnikles à la gamberge c'est
pire qu'à un claquage la pensée en
jouant au ballon c'est fini il ya de
jeunes boxeurs qu'on essaie de
transformer en tueur professionnel aussi
c'est voilà à chaque fois d'ailleurs on
on n'est pas toujours sûr le personnage
dont on parle dans ce boxeur mais
l'entraîneur puis ensuite le masseur
puis ensuite le sophrologue tous nous
tous ces gens qui s'occupent de lui il
va se répandre comme ça
comme on le suppose comme on imagine
parce que souvent que ce soit le
tennisman une cycliste il repère
quelqu'un dans le public comme ça alors
par exemple le cycliste y voit une femme
il imagine qu'elle est nu il se met à
penser à un strip tease lépi bon voila
il perd quoi c'est oui où il croise le
regard d'une femme comme ça dont il
tombe amoureux puis commencer à rêver
sur l eau tout c'est aussi avec une
bande son qui nous met tout de suite
dans l'ambiance d'une bombe sur un
contre mais c'est vrai la bande son est
très bien maurice edu c'est un show
c'est un spectacle à chaque fois le
sport maintenant donc il ya même il ya
même des commentateurs il ya un elson
monfort qui est là qui dit quelques
phrases fusent sur un joueur de tennis
alors vous aimez pas trop vous dévoiler
voix moi je sais qu'une fois vous êtes
venus ici même raconté par le biais des
roulettes pour vous faire avouer tron
avec isabelle adjani ça m'a pris un
quart d'heure vous dites
l'hyperconsommation de la vie réelle des
comédiens et dangereuse quoi andré tu es
né à annecy pourquoi ce choix
on va faire avec une interview dans la
vraie vie c'est normal
alors andré est ce que dans votre vraie
vie il ya des coups de théâtre pour vos
à oui j'adore ça vous arrive comme un
oui oui
ouais je sillonne les rues dans l'espoir
qui aura un coup de théâtre
enfin le croisement avec votre femme
fait relâche lundi
non maintenant les trois comme c'est
mignon mais c'est de répondre ça c'est
les trois coups derrière
dans les trois coups non et 3 plus dans
la vraie vie vous arrive de vous jouer
la comédie à vous même à moi même
peut-être pas trop non
non aux autres de la journée abba ou ça
peut arriver oui ça peut être le jeu est
assez agréable aussi c'est une
déformation professionnelle dans la
vraie vie vous avez déjà pensé à changer
de partenaire oui bien sûr ouais bien
sûr oui ça peut arriver comme ça c'est
facile de rêver un de passiez un nom
quand on la voit on peut ensemble
est ce que dans la vraie vie vous
changez souvent de décor oui j'aime bien
ça voyager toute façon même changer de
décor il suffit de rester chez moi pour
changer de décor assez facilement
est-ce que j'ai eu un long entracte dans
votre couple attention a précédé ce
kimono réponse ça peut arriver les
entrailles tu mets ça permet de bien
repartir pour la suite
il ya une scène dans la vraie vie que
vous ne vous lassez jamais de jouer en
dhr eh oui le matin au réveil j'adore
sahara et chapiteaux ces grands
chapiteaux des mots
faites dans leur famille aux terres
[Musique]